Philip: My wife, Elizabeth. Paige, Henry.
Paige: Hi.
Philip: And what do you do, Stan?
Stan: I'm an FBI agent.
[laughs]
Jack Barsky: This scene is very realistic.
Hello, my name is Jack Barsky.
I spied on behalf of the KGB for 10 years,
1978 to 1988.
And in 2014, I became a US citizen.
Today, I'm gonna play movie
critic based on my experience,
my actual experience in espionage.
This is something that could
have happened in real life.
How you clear a dead drop.
Those kinds of false coins existed.
The way he then opens
the coin by using tools
that are readily available,
and the fact that there was
a little piece of paper
with some information on it,
it's quite realistic because, you know,
I got bits and pieces of information
through shortwave radio,
and I transmitted information
in a film cartridge
where I photographed the stuff
that I wrote down on paper.
I would occasionally
wander around in a park,
and oh, boy, here's an oil can,
it was a crushed oil can.
I'd take that, take it home,
and then use some pliers
and screwdrivers to open this thing up,
and voilà, there was a
passport and money in there.
[door bangs]
I know this story quite well.
Abel was considered a hero in the KGB
while I was in training.
I don't know if he was still
alive when I was in Moscow.
It has been documented from both sides
with a lot of exaggeration.
Both the Americans and the
Soviets played up his worth,
what he actually did and
what he accomplished.
What happens in situations like that;
you can use agents
once they're caught for
propaganda services.
I doubt that the FBI stormed his apartment
the way that they did.
It looks unprofessional.
Why are you running?
What you do, if you wanna
search somebody's apartment,
you wait until they're out,
and then you do that in secret.
That's the way my house was searched.
While I was on vacation.
The FBI made a mistake:
once they're in there, to
allow Abel to touch anything.
I would give it probably an eight.
Does disservice to the
professionalism of the FBI.
Everything else is really very realistic.
Alex: Your profile interests us.
You have talents and skills
that we can help you develop.
Anna: You're offering me a job?
Alex: I'm offering you a fresh start.
One year's military training;
four years operational in the field.
Jack: The recruitment
and training of people
who would do things like, you know,
go to another country and do
bad things to good people.
I only know about this
from secondhand reports.
The KGB had a very,
very murderous history,
particularly in the beginning.
After Stalin died, they became
a little more civilized,
but they were still doing bad things.
My recruitment was completely different.
It was a very, very soft approach,
and it took a long time,
about almost two years,
to finally ask me if I
was willing and ready
to join them.
I was a third-year student at university
when somebody introduced himself.
His cover was, at the time, he said,
"I'm a representative
from a local business."
And he wanted to just
know, because he told me,
"We know that you're a good student.
What are your plans after
you graduate from college?"
In those days in East Germany,
you were assigned to a post
once you graduated from college.
At that point, when he said that,
I thought he was Stasi,
East German secret police.
To me, it was a great honor,
'cause, you know, in those
days the Soviet Union was,
strength-wise, at least
the way we perceived it,
the equal to the United States,
and the KGB probably was
the most powerful secret
service in the entire world.
I would still think
it's highly unrealistic.
I would give that a zero.
Stan: Hey!
Philip: Phil Jennings.
Stan: How you doing? Stan Beeman.
Philip: My wife, Elizabeth. Paige, Henry.
Paige: Hi.
Philip: What do you do, Stan?
Stan: I'm an FBI agent.
[laughs]
Jack: This scene is very realistic.
There were 10 of us.
We were supposed to live a
life of ordinary Americans.
Now, how the two kids fit into there,
especially already at that age,
there were some agents that had children.
I know a friend of mine
who was an undercover agent for the KGB
at the same time I was there,
and he was there with his wife, actually.
They had a kid who was born in Brooklyn.
My own experience was
a little bit different
in that the FBI,
when they started investigating me,
they managed to buy the house next door.
Agents occupied this house for
a number of months to just watch me,
but they never really
did introduce themselves.
This was just for purposes of observation,
which, when I became a public persona,
the producers of "The Americans"
were, like, really giddy
in that it appeared that
life was imitating art
in that respect.
Spies are people too.
You do form relationships.
There wasn't even a hint
of something like that
ever being considered.
Philip: Nothing. You get nothing from us.
She's trained for this.
So am I.
Elizabeth: We'll die before we'll talk.
Philip: And we know how to do that.
Jack: The Americans are quite civilized.
This is a quote I remember.
One of the guys told me,
"They will not torture you.
The worst thing they might do to you
is slap you on the face
a couple of times."
All right? So, therefore,
this scene is unrealistic from both ends.
This is not how US
counterintelligence operates,
and this is not how a
trained agent would respond.
That's over-the-top insane.
The way these two agents
supposedly operated,
running a travel agency full time,
being full-time parents,
and then doing all kinds of,
being involved in all kinds of operations
that require a lot of
work, a lot of preparation,
that require you to be
in three different
places at the same time,
all of this is totally unrealistic.
I told him, every time I see
one of those main characters
running around with a wig,
I wince, because that's the
last thing that you wanna do,
because God forbid somebody
spots you and says,
"Wait a minute, I know this guy.
He looks different.
What? That's odd."
Wigs, I mean, that's a total no-no.
With one exception.
The people that work surveillance,
they sometimes change the way they dress.
They change a jacket
or they put a scarf on.
But that's not ever
recommended for somebody
who was supposed to be a long-term
operational undercover agent.
On content I would give
"The Americans" a five.
[shouting]
[fire blasting]
Rosa: Training is useful,
but there is no substitute for experience.
Morzeny: I agree; we use
live targets as well.
[laughs]
Jack: This was very entertaining.
I laughed, particularly at the sentence,
"We use live targets."
This whole training setup,
even from a fictional aspect,
it doesn't make any sense.
The KGB clearly had bad guys,
but this fellow with a leather jacket;
I never met a KGB officer
with a leather jacket.
If you met them today
the way they were then,
you would think they were
just normal everyday people.
That's the whole point of being a spy.
You don't wanna look like one.
This guy looks like a commissar,
based on the way they were dressed
during the revolutionary times in Russia.
The KGB was too compartmentalized.
You know, I met nothing but gentlemen;
gentlemen who operated on
behalf of the Soviet Union
for a cause, and we were
all committed communists.
But if they had tried
to make a military unit
out of the folks that I worked with,
[laughs] we would have
lost the first battle.
All of a sudden, she has a
weapon in her shoe. [laughs]
There's a KGB museum in New York City,
and they have some real gadgets
that were used by the KGB.
They would be given to, most likely,
only very special people
who were executing
a particular, very special assignment.
Just, like, go out and kill
somebody or poison somebody.
But this was not standard equipment.
Any of these gadgets are evidence
if counterintelligence
goes through your home
and they find even one thing
with a secret compartment.
I was operating within
the universe of what's normal,
and you can find a whole lot
of things that you can use
for tools and toys that
you can buy in any store.
It's a minus one. [laughs]
Happy: Rule No. 1, never
take your eye off your--
Pepper: Oh, my God!
Jack: Yeah, I like the acting.
It's interesting.
My training in self-defense
was significantly less aggressive.
I learned a handful of moves.
I did get some self-defense training,
not to attack FBI
or, you know, counterintelligence,
but to defend myself
in case I wind up at one point
in a dangerous neighborhood
with some stuff on me,
like money or compromising materials.
That's all the weapons training I got.
This is killer training
here, what we're looking at.
KGB contingent was called Spetsnaz.
The special forces, like the Marines.
They were trained for these
special type of operations.
We're jumping ahead of ourselves
to think that anything
that's out in the media
and in movies and podcasts and whatever
will get really close
to the absolute truth.
I'll even...a five.
It's well filmed. These
are first-rate actors.
Orlov: The name of the
Russian agent is Salt.
Evelyn Salt.
Salt: My name is Evelyn Salt.
Orlov: Then you are a Russian spy.
Lie detector: Truthful.
Agent: So far, the fMRI scan
registers truthful on everything he said.
Jack: This is pure fiction
on a number of levels.
First of all, sleepers
were completely isolated.
In other words, I couldn't betray anybody
even if I wanted to.
The Russians did this very well;
we call this compartmentalization.
There is no such thing as a brain scan
that will help you discover the truth.
I was still subjected
to a lie-detector test,
which the FBI still likes a lot,
but it can be defeated.
You have to really,
really believe in the lie
and be a congenital liar.
Double agents existed, and
there was a couple of cases
where the KGB had a mole within the FBI
and within the CIA who
did a lot of damage.
If I may, I give it a double zero.
Interrogator: Are you
working for the Americans?
Dominika: I love my country.
[bone cracking]
Jack: This is taking
KGB practices of the '30s,
'40s, into the early '50s
and moving them forward into sort of
a contemporary scene, and that's invalid.
The KGB was absolutely brutal
in interrogating people,
shooting them in the back of the head
and using all kinds of
brutality, which is unimaginable.
It was very similar to what the Nazis did.
This is one of the torture methods.
You put a board or something
to prevent real injuries,
bruises, and stuff like that.
But to the head?
Interrogator: Last time.
Did you give Boucher to the Americans?
Jack: Means are much more subtle
and much more psychological
than this kind of stuff.
You threaten somebody with a gun,
if they get out of it,
they will hate you forever.
There's a number of ways
to make somebody switch.
A threat to your family;
that's a very, very strong incentive.
When you have somebody who is like I,
I lived in the United States for 10 years,
and I had gotten used to some...
a significant improved lifestyle.
I had become an American in many respects.
I think sexpionage, that's reality.
I'd be surprised if there are any
major intelligence services
that aren't in some way
recruiting women to do dirty work.
I would not recommend this.
[typewriter whirring]
Ricki: Then the message comes through.
"We read you."
Jack: This thing starts typing,
and the fellow happens to be in the place
where it starts typing.
Well, how do we know that he's there?
There is no real way for somebody
who was truly in isolation
to give somebody an urgent message.
The fastest way for me to have
received an urgent message
in those days was through signals.
And that would be with a possible delay
of about a day or at least a half a day.
Let's say in the evening
the agent sends the signal.
In the morning I read it.
Is it possible to intercept
a teletype message?
I don't know, because
I think in those days,
radio transmissions would
have been preferable,
and they wouldn't just
come on spontaneously.
If you wanna hand over
documentation about,
say, a weapons system, how do you do this?
The easiest way is to, if you can,
you steal it and put
it on electronic media.
But if it's just a real short message,
such as, "Get out of here," a phone call,
but you have to be now aware
that phone calls are traced.
There's also communication
that the messages
are compressed and transmitted
in bursts, in short bursts,
and then they get
decompressed at the other end.
But, again, that has to be scheduled.
Numbers stations, if you go
into a short radio receiver
and you go and scan shortwaves,
you will occasionally hear something
when somebody says,
"Five, eight, six, nine."
That's a secret message
for somebody to be decoded.
Ricki: I looked for her everywhere.
I couldn't find her at the airport,
and I even looked through
all the flight lists.
I headed down to the harbor.
Man: Faster!
Jack: In this business,
if you have an asset -
and we're talking about asset,
it's a human being who
is working with you -
you wanna do everything to protect them.
You know, we're talking
an agent who was trying
to protect a Russian
who was working with him.
I think that's entirely realistic.
Tom: Hey, Jim, me and
Eileen have been figuring
you could use little entertainment.
Petrofsky: Yes, all right.
Thank you, that would be lovely.
Jack: Well, the purported agent
is way too good looking.
We think that Brosnan
is actually a Russian.
He has no accent.
There is no such thing as
a Russian born in Russia,
raised in Russia,
can speak English without an accent.
[pins clattering]
Tom: Goddamn!
Eileen: You're pretty good, Jimmy!
Tom: Yeah, too damn good.
Jack: You'll be yourself.
You know, if you're good
at something, you show off.
You play along. That was the whole idea.
You want to befriend a lot of people
and you just wanna blend
in the best you can.
You don't wanna stand out too much.
You know, I made a big mistake.
I went back to college in the US,
and I aced the entire program.
But, you know, showing off
bowling skills, why not?
If you're a good golfer,
somebody may wanna play golf with you,
and then that's how you get to know people
that might be of interest.
This was very entertaining.
I laughed,
particularly at the sentence,
"We use live targets."